Mobile devices not only have different numbers of actual
pixels, but they fit very different numbers of pixels
into each inch of screen real estate. So, to
get roughly consistent formatting, they pass different numbers of layout
pixels into the view port. This chart shows the
number of physical pixels for each device, the device pixel
ratio. And then the resulting layout viewport. If we
look at the number of device independent pixels per inch,
this results in for each of these devices, we'll
note that almost all the mobile devices are very
close to 160 device independent pixels per inch. This
makes layout design much easier for us. The device pixel
ratio gives you a clue as to how high
resolution the screen really is. Not just how many
layout pixels there are. You can use device pixel
ratio in media queries to control properties like background images.
And in fact, this is going to become very interesting in
the next lesson, where we learn about how to use adaptive images.